سواء كنت على الشاطئ أو في
الفناء الخلفي هذا الصيف ، فإن ممارسة
عادات الترطيب الجيدة أمر ضروري ، فأنت تحصل على
بعض الماء من خلال الأطعمة مثل الفواكه والخضروات ،
لكن 80 في المائة من
ترطيبك يأتي من الماء والسوائل الأخرى ،
لذا قم بتنظيف H2O IQ باستخدام
هذا  اختبار سريع هنا يكون صحيحًا أو
خاطئًا ، دع عطشك يكون دليلك ،
هذا خاطئ ، فأنت تريد أن تتغلب على
عطشك ، فأنت لا تريد أن
تشعر بالعطش عندما تشعر بالعطش ، فأنت بالفعل تعاني من
الجفاف بشكل معتدل ، ما يعادل ثمانية
أوقيات من الماء يوميًا
كافية ، هذا خطأ أيضًا ، هذا هو
الحد الأدنى الذي تبدأ به مع تلك الثمانية
وتراكم من هناك ، وتهدف إلى الحصول على حوالي
تسعة أكواب للنساء و 12 للرجال
سواء أكان ذلك من الصنبور أو المعبأة في زجاجات
فقط لأن الماء يخرج من الزجاجة
لا يعني أنها أكثر أمانًا  بعد ذلك ، بعض
المشروبات ترطب أكثر من غيرها ، إنها
حقيقة أن الماء هو سياسة ترطيب مثالية
التمسك بالماء بعض
المشروبات التي تحتوي على الكافيين لا بأس بها ولكن كن حذرًا من
نصائح الكحول لمساعدتك على التفكير أو
إعادة  أعتقد أن شرابك من أجل دقيقة الصحة اليوم
أنا سوزان هندريكس